all right my darling no screw this i'm
trying a different intro didn't work
didn't work anyway no man's sky is out I
have been waiting for this game just so
long and the size of it just mine
bobbles me there is so much to explore
and do so I wanted to share my first
experiences playing it with you guys in
a live stream and here are the
highlights from that stream I always
when did you start with the ship or do
you just start on your own I love the
art for this game that's one thing that
drew me to the same as soon as I started
seeing all of their all the support I
just saw it looked awesome
initialization secret okay so there's my
lil [ __ ] it's red which is good to my
favorite colors red guy that it looks
like the whole planet is red this is
good not it may should first are from
that's our planet moshe first differ
whoo you have unredeemed items to claim
please use options menu why what's this
now rename and upload let's rename okay
what should we name our star system oh
okay well should we name our star system
guys I guess should know I want the
planet to be called Yard Man X so the
star system can be called broccoli I
don't know controller think of something
like an in-joke Oh could be like terror
the terror system that'll be quite scary
wouldn't it oh yeah gua yag system okay
I like yummy way we're going for that
Liza yeah I don't know what I'm doing
this is our little ship
oh we can get in there here we go I can
launch the toaster critically damaged so
this is what I need to get a vital
launch landing gear system ok so I can't
do any of that and a fight space
propulsion huh huh huh give me out
the distress beacon reality seems to
fold in on itself ah if the text is
always going to be on this side I'll
move my head cuz I'm gonna annoy me
could this be the face of creation
itself or in my hazy fresh awakened
state am I being manipulated a name
burns itself onto my hand atlas it's
atlas should we just explore freely or
shall we accept the guidance I can't
like Atlas they I'll accept because
you're nice I feel secure the warm glow
of approval I was lost but now I'm found
the Atlas acknowledges my allegiance
okay yay thanks Alice you're awesome um
damage machinery new technology
discovered photon cannon cool down times
are significantly reduced map I get it
right it and to collect parts and then I
can make stuff for my ship that's weird
this reminds weaver did anyone ever play
um iron there are you what's the new
your pumpkin
how do I destroy this Oh like this hey I
got a little gun whoa this is like
Minecraft but in space but you start
with a gun oh this is gonna take forever
look at this this is ridiculous what the
hell oh why am I drives before much cool
Oh overheated whoo nice what oh my god
it's you who is what are you doing hey
analysis visor critically damaged but
all right I was trying to use my
analysis visor I didn't realize what I
was doing I was just trying to UM aim
no no no no no are you
and still overheated I just sounds again
just let me just let me repair my
Spanish it okay where my guy funny how
everyone can run
oh yeah I keep on trying to aim and it's
like I notice is broken what mm-hmm I
like I'll use a Frankenstein quotes
okay that was weird
okay why at least I just died down the
road let's go collect the stuff Your
Grave oh this is where I was oh thanks
given my sup create a new check to
upgrade your equipment go on then what
do I want user is able to run for
expended how do I run I don't even know
how to run what I can run how do I run
tell me or do this system incorporates a
brainless spinal puncture painless
spinal puncture no smoke another thing
um epidural tap insertion and bodily
brother like that let me look at them
maybe this will actually let me run yeah
thanks this all goes to my spaceship so
I won't lose this yag my news right
state hopefully yeah what I was clicking
you the last stick ah that's why i was
saying scanners cricket weaker damage
well this makes sense now why don't they
tell me this before saves me so much
time so for those of you that don't
really know too much about no man's sky
it's an exploration game space and stuff
but it's all finally generators or even
the developers of the game don't know
what's on each planet which I thought
was pretty darn here that's where I died
already died I don't pretend to be you
know the best gamer
go ahead do for fun okay oh yes okay so
I need to make a co-writer sheet okay
right and you instructed lunch the
massage woohoo okay so we need to write
sheet I'm understanding the game guys
did you see the little cog for my brain
going then go in veridia correct she
don't why we will get in the air soon
just let me get you some scheme okay I
probably should have played it first got
used to it but you get to see my jeffy
movements us what that's why you like me
right to get to see madera moments
that's what i tell myself anyway right
zinc Herodium courage sheet Judas ah ket
instructed guys what else did I say
because I forgot what's this oh I can do
this T optical enhancement and creature
discovery Oh allow user to tag in London
twerk
ah this is so cool it really reminds me
of a young Knievel because you you would
explore the kind of a weird ish world
and she would take photos of all the
cool little creatures that you find and
I thought I'm very fun let's go find go
have a look up here oh oh my god it's so
beautiful what I did put it on a little
bit just saying but it is nice ah cute
he's just like Gigi's shaking it don't
take that the wrong way need a damn oh
okay well this is cool showing 1 stuff
it's around I'll just give you them
wheel loads of robotic things I don't
think they'd mind me unless I start
blowing up the planet which I can julie
understand it's not really somebody
right for anything to do is it don't
hurt me I'm not destroying your land i
swear i put the gun away okay thanks ah
what do i do how do i like scan him
hi hey don't tell me I'm trying to kill
you because I already don't want to kill
you I like you a lot I think you're cool
you're elderly and radical your of a
radical gender your magical gender you
are an ambulatory you're a vegetarian um
cool I'm happy with what about you you
still cute you're so tiny you didn't
like you know Oh My sainted twice look a
little dragon good legs oh yeah you're
so cool I love you guys I'm off I'm
gonna I'm gonna do stuff sorry go get
dad and mr. Troyan rock dog is good just
this time books if you could write the
alien things here that will be so cool
oh oh oh I don't want them to catch me
because I know it can't defeat them good
I'm rubbished I rubbish is okay I've
lived with it my whole life I can live
with it tonight what's that weird noise
hi I'm not doing anything to your world
oh god oh god oh god oh god I
accidentally shot I didn't mean to do
that but I'm gonna kill you anyway now
I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill you
you're probably gonna kill me oh god no
oh god no oh god this I ever hate it
so I thought I was gonna die so I got
really excited when I realized I didn't
die I'm trying to get the sauce oh yeah
i can run journey my son cop fished
booyaa i'm just trying to chase after
the barrel though I'm a novice what was
i before a noob okay at least I'm a
novice now stop rolling down this
freakin hell barrel I want to get you
and your parts you are mine okay come
here come here stop it give me my
infantry is fault stop okay stop stop
stop I command you stop okay that was
that was a trek okay let's send some of
this back to the ship would not have fun
enjoy oh that's my [ __ ] given to you
okay let's charge some of this stuff
Oh what is that a fancy okay let's give
up that way you found another way fun
Hey Oh yo yo yo yo calm yourself I'm not
gonna helm yeah defensive i can tell
that i can definitely tell that this is
the cool tree hey it's okay dragon with
legs give me kids room I mean what I do
whatever okay I need to get up there
somehow oh it's dark now tell him I like
okay I'm thinking how am I gonna that do
I have to get on top was it just all of
this thing
ah oh that hat okay I'm not doing that
again that was silly
oh I made a hole that's cool now can
hide
so cool I made little bass I can hide
from the zombies in here this isn't
minecraft I think I'm being careless
yeah like surely you would die if you
did this right how am I gonna pay am i
cold we're going down there help me I is
good on ya what do you think guys do
think I can make it maybe we can make
ourselves a little yeah I'm sure we can
make it ah I don't regret that it's okay
we serve I case you try and get back to
the ship I think you've got everything
that we need yeah we do sweet hey Johnny
Martin we're making progress gosh it
you know I jumped down how am I gonna
get back up guys didn't think about this
I did not think this through oh okay all
right we can make this did you ever used
to do this and like Skyrim and stuff
just try and climb up the highest
mountains I used to do that I used to
spend hours just doing that hey we're
doing it with defying gravity screw you
gravity I have boosters cool hey cacti
oh wait I need for um I think I need to
find some help so healthier by cuz i'm
an idiot if you've gone her and myself
what's another one we just accomplished
one what are you talking about boom
we're travelers guys we set out we lost
atlas but we did it
I assume I see you I see you I see let
me see you let me see you on it I am ah
your new high praise I'm concerned
you're unconcerned oh sorry I thought I
figured talk to you can I talk to you
it's for one second i want to feed you
something niacin I am what made with
your tail his mouth is like an a plant
isn't it okay I can walk faster you can
run
yes please what's this I'll pull get me
up safely
next time you do get nip this is like
health get Nick edible much loved by the
GECK yeah yeah ghek allows beaked
traders to release delightfully scented
packs of gas oh it's not food then
giving it gas packets are considered an
art form and the truest reputation what
is he is for what do I use that for it's
an edible product right I eat it what
can I eat it decks are a species I know
gex but like this get nip like what i
use that for do I some joy I'm a MTG
deck soon and maybe I get them some get
nip okay guys which one wait which one
looks like a little odd I don't care
about the plants they're boring which
which one looks like a yak minion I
think this one would you say that one
represents the yag minion
yeah getting good luck Oh what can I
feed you can i feed any of you let me
feed you please let me feed you the iron
again can I righty now please you happy
creature is so cute again music but come
with your friends can you follow me like
I'm like we can play fetch or something
Wow come on
can you get me oh my god don't stand me
what I was a bit too close I think I can
feed you where are you a vegetarian
canicula animals in this I really don't
want to try just in case you're not
supposed to do that for already guilty
so i don't think i'm going to unless i
get coast whoa oh dear that's not a good
idea oh that was scary I say what right
off the edge there that would have been
stupid
hey
yeah i launched my stash so poor boy
wait wait wait wait from the videos it
like I could fly down close to the
errors can do that one author has the
planet community done cool I can do that
it's a little bit cake saline but it's
okay all right let's go fly fly Sasha
into space what is that all right that's
another planet
yay oh yeah we caught a Harley old
galaxy yeah you were arrived in three
hours acquire a hyperdrive challenge i
know i arrived in three hours and in
serious and what else is around oh I
don't have them to have guns on my
spaceship okay I'll keep that in mind
how do i do own eyes I want to shoot at
the freakin planet while I do in Oh
stupid yag man that's okay no one's
coming out I thought I come in peace I
can I piece I'm just destroying the
meteor
to aim with the right stick and the
press X to fire then once you let go of
the stick to press X whatever
I guess I prayed the whole [ __ ] around
ah there you are this is son oh wow hmm
don't if you have too long you'll burn
your eyes oh I pulse engine is off land
insufficient fuel ah man I gotcha so
let's just do this
let's do this for you love something
with fire in its eyes this species is
clearly aggressive and I doubt unwelcome
yet the life-form bowels in greeting
well that sounds okay tradition and
honor perhaps dictate it I don't feel in
imminent danger and i'm about to town
and leave when the quick two points
towards my multi-tool it Abe arts with
concern and make some emergen to suggest
that I should hand it over um
Parveez was to give him and just
thinking you know he bowed to us perhaps
he's just gonna make it better should we
just give him that more usual and hope
that he may be adds to it and then and
then gives it back should we do that
sure will be I don't think that's
something I would do I'm too I'm too
nice though ok ok I'll handover worry it
not some satisfaction yes it offers me
an improved replacement yeah we were
good reem Gary see trust trust the weird
aliens trust them and they would you get
I don't always have ya boy that's weird
I want a new word please i wanna i'm
glad you guys
I learned Viking Amy serious oh what a
cop out you just didn't didn't have to
teach her something JimBob oops so loud
another
I learned five words I'm a battler I
remember Bob prefect the prefect no one
said any of the other words what I know
it's not fair the warrior is signing for
a second before Luke hear me confront
conspiratorial E and it's behind to
check for its colleagues before I'm
before powering down security systems
the warrior polls open the trade fault
at its feet which seems to be piled high
with multi-tool upgrades or it indicates
the contents of my inventory as a trade
threaten to report
should be a goody two shoes and for
enter for that's it
she pull up my silence will hear my
phone nice I hope you enjoy that if you
did make sure to follow me on twitter
where I tweet out when I'm gonna do all
of my livestreams right here on YouTube
gaming i'll be playing more of no man's
sky finishing off the evil within and
doing other live streams as well i'd
love for you guys or come along it's a
great atmosphere we all chat we all have
a great time and I just absolutely love
doing streams for you give this a thumbs
up if you enjoyed and let me know your
thoughts on no man's sky down in the
comments below I hope you have a lovely
dehradun go go go go go go do you guys
ever wonder how you would fare inner
inner chase you know something like this
how well would you call it Bloody ell
but he's gonna get us if he don't get us